rescue teams are searching for survivors
after a shallow earthquake struck
Indonesia's main island the magnitude
5.4 Quake was centered around the West
Java Province at least 14 people have
been killed shaking was felt as far away
as the capital Jakarta where tall
buildings swayed for several minutes
officials say buildings and houses are
damaged
joining us on the line from Jakarta is
Jessica Washington so Jessica what are
we hearing about the aftermath of this
quake
well Sammy this is still very much a
developing situation the earthquake
struck at around 620 GMT so around 120
local time and as you mentioned uh
magnitude of according to local
authorities A 5.6 at a depth of 10
kilometers so the significance here is
not so much the magnitude which is
relatively compared to earthquakes
Indonesia has experienced in the past uh
not particularly strong the concern here
is the depth and also the location that
this earthquake had an epicenter that
was on land 10 kilometers Southwest of
chiangular in West Java here in the
capital Jakarta I was out and did feel
those mild Tremors and people respond
responding to those as they always do
Indonesia is Indonesians are quite used
to natural disasters and so people
evacuated their offices and some
apartment complexes and gathered at
emergency assembly points as for the
area surrounding the epicenter itself we
understand that hospital and some
mosques and schools are reportedly
damaged and some social media footage
appears to show people injured some of
them bleeding injuries to the face as
well the death toll as we understand now
according to the National Agency for
disaster counter mitigation is standard
around 14 but some local authorities on
the ground say that the death toll could
be 20 or indeed even more the the
difficulties for authorities at this
point include the disruption to
Communications some issues which with
reaching some areas some affected areas
injur since the earthquake in just a few
short hours the there have been 25
aftershocks recorded so far worth noting
the context for that specific area it's
quite a hilly area not not a
particularly no particular major cities
but but still quite a populist area and
some problems with infrastructure poor
construction of homes and and that sort
of thing so those are the factors that
authorities will have to deal with as
they search for survivors and attempt to
assist those in need and the context
broadly for Indonesia Indonesia sits on
the Pacific ring of fire so Indonesians
are very much accustomed to natural
disasters and Indonesian authorities are
also accustomed to dealing with
situations such as this
all right we'll leave you there thanks
so much Jessica